les gestes sont encore hésitants mais la
volonté est bien présente karaté bushido
taï jitsu encore aïkido des novices ont
pu tester ce samedi 10 mars une dizaine
d'arts martiaux venus des contrées
asiatiques
photo prend bien j'ai fait ça est
compris et j
c'est ça une fois pour les combats je
dire les techniques pour apprendre à se
défendre avec les enfants les adultes se
sont également prêtés au jeu
ils ont appris pendant cette journée a
esquivé à contrer ou à maîtriser des
techniques avec l'aide des clubs locaux
on a essayé le taï shi tzu et ben ça
nous a bien plu puisque on a fait des
exercices au moins 15 différents sur
votre à ce qu'une heure on était venus
pour essayer dix minutes un quart
d'heure et puis on est resté j'ai appris
plein de choses aujourd'hui
objectif annoncé de l'événement faire
découvrir les 13 associations d'arts
martiaux de montigny le bretonneux et
surtout convertir les 1000 participants
leur discipline il ya des gens qui ont
pris nos coordonnées
ils vont venir enfin ils ont déjà essayé
ici vont venir essayer au sein du club
certains avaient peur parce qu'on leur a
montré beaucoup de technique on leur
expliquait que là aujourd'hui c'est une
initiation leur montrer un panel pour
leur faire goûter pour leur donner envie
mais au sein du club on présente
effectivement qu une deux voire trois
techniques maximum pour qu'ils aient le
temps de se les approprier les
maîtrisards pour convaincre
définitivement les débutants encore un
peu hésitant la journée s'est clôturée
par un spectacle sur les différents arts
martiaux et des mises en scène
l'opération séduction devrait avoir
fonctionné